let's bring out right now one of the
great neighbors I met here in Harlem
please welcome my new friend Vivian wood
Drago
[Music]
[Applause]
it was great absolutely G you were such
a highlight I shot for a couple of hours
I was talking and you literally just
walked into the shot and started singing
and we hit it off right away and that
all really happened just as you saw it
and you were amazing
now you work
you work around the corner right you
work around the corner at the New York
foundling a child welfare agency here in
Harlem is that way this is the best job
and your family that they got the
t-shirt so they thank you so much thank
you okay good I'm glad I got the shirts
you have a beautiful voice you just
started singing you were great and I was
thinking that she can really sing and
then I found out that you've been on
this stage before at the Apollo
and it didn't go well what happened is a
true story so it was when I was like in
the eleventh grade it was Wednesday
night Amateur Night at the Apollo during
intermission they're like does anybody
want to come down and sing so me
thinking I'm like the Devo was like I'm
gonna come down so I was like all the
way up here came all the way down here
and I love Stevie Wonder he's like my
favorite are there and and so I love I
never dreamy leave in summer so I'm like
oh but and everybody was like boo but my
friends will never let me die with it
they were everywhere we go we get this
one note write one note all right this
is what I want to do I wanted to give
you the opportunity to sing again hit
that this time hit that note just right
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I thought you would go there and come
back home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I thought Nicole would leave by summer
[Music]
now I find myself all alone
Oh
oh hello
hello
[Applause]
right here we have an amazing show
tonight from Silicon Valley the
hilarious TJ Miller
we the guests the Sugar Hill Gang
[Applause]
we'll be right back Jimmy take it away
[Applause]
you
you